thank you maurice yes i'm here with
irina bulma
one of the leading players in the world
uh the top romanian player
and a good friend of mine irina welcome
back uh to bucharest
actually this is your home city how does
it feel to see
all these top players in your home city
it is uh just amazing to see all of them
playing here
i've never experienced this before and
i'm just touring for our guys and i hope
that they can play their best chess here
and
yeah that feels amazing um we've had a
lot of problems during the past year and
a half with the pandemic as
chess players how did you handle that
and we know that you just played an over
the board tournament
how did that feel coming back to over
the board chess well it definitely was a
challenge to keep
going through this year because every
time you think
okay prepare for the next tournament but
which one is the next tournament so i
actually took up some different things
so i did some courses and stuff like
that but it felt
amazing to be at the chessboard again
and i'm just looking forward to more
tournaments
and meanwhile i hope that the
preparation which is
uh cubiting the games and analyzing them
will
will do well for me speaking of
preparation did you usually uh prepare
openings or did you focus on other
aspects of the game during the
pandemic let's say because we had uh
leveronian and he was saying that
for the rapid events that he was playing
the opening preparation didn't really
matter too much
well actually i've tried to change a lot
in the opening part of my preparation
but i did other things as well
um but um well i guess i'm a player who
is based a lot on openings and that's
probably my biggest strength that i'm
very flexible as a chess player when
choosing those openings
and i have like a big pleasure finding
those novelties
and seeing well i believe this uh
game of lupu today might be one where uh
some novelties absolutely since uh i
have you here
on the set let's actually have a look at
this game
you were mentioning during the break
that you've actually played
this position with grieschuk's wife yes
i just played the women's feeder grand
prix in gibraltar and
there with the black pieces i played
against the katarina lafner
this classic sicilian which turned up
into a rouser later
though she chose here instead of f4 she
chose
uh to play the plan with afri and
uh well that was a tough game she won
in the end what are the differences
between f4 and f3 in terms of
let's say plans what are the immediate
differences oh well actually
uh after a free white basically goes
mostly for g-force
and h-force and stuff like that
okay katarina played h4 against me
instead of g4 and then i played
h6 bishop e3 h5 and then eventually the
bishop returned
at some point bishop of six would come
on the board somehow the center here is
more stable than in the once with f4
but on the other hand when white plays
f4 there is this
idea of playing f5 and then the
different of course
you probably know even better because i
know you like to play the open sicilian
i have to say i have to say
i play this the last time maybe 10 15
years ago with the white pieces
before i started playing d4 and the
only game that i remember is a game that
i lost in one of the most important
games of my life in some european
championship
and that just haunts me so i don't like
seeing these type of structures at least
with the white pieces
but uh right now we have this position
on the board lukasco seems to be
playing quite quickly do you have any
experience
training with him did you teach him this
no actually i didn't but i know that
that he should be well prepared here and
i believe that he has a great position
here because while the knight on g3 is
really not well placed
while playing for the d5 square and
that's like the main downside of having
this
e5 on board the bishop is also not on on
that diagonal i mean on a2 g8 so
i i definitely like the prospects of
black i mean a 5x4
is coming and i'm hoping for for some
good results
some excitement definitely some
excitement on the board on this one
now that you're back to over the board
chess what are your plans for
this year oh well actually today i'm
heading to the romanian
national team blitz and rapid
championship
and then i will be playing the world's
cup in sochi and actually
uh there are a lot of us romanians going
there so there will be four of us
and i hope some of us can go as far as
possible i definitely plan
to try that super busy tournament
schedule
very exciting to see you back on the
board thank you very much for joining us
thank you guys back to